[Music]
vice president kamala harris has called
it a national emergency the impact this
pandemic is having on women in the
workforce
more than two million women have left
the workforce because they were forced
to stay home to manage child care and
virtual learning
creating the pink recession in order to
get our economy back employers are
scrambling for answers on how to help
women return to the workforce
we connected with holly kaplan she's a
confidence coach for women who want to
reinvent themselves
and she had some great advice to share
it takes a heck of a lot of confidence
to walk right back into the job market
if you have been at home
and under stress of home life so
the first thing i recommend is get your
confidence back
and i have a couple of ways that you can
do that and the first one is
make a list of your skills think about
your special skills
pre-coded like maybe before code when
you were in marketing
you were really creative or you were in
sales management you're a really good
coach whatever those
things were and are that make you
special
write them down because whatever they
may be you're going to take those
forward with you
and to your next role the second thing
i'd like to say is
i'm a list maker make a list of your
accomplishments
when you look at everything that you
have done and worked so hard for
again you will remind yourself why you
are successful all right have that list
out the next thing
network it's a dynamic way to get
reconnected with the workforce she says
choose five different women with jobs
you admire
schedule one-on-ones with each of them
letting them know you're in the job
market
share your skills and ask how you can
get your resume to the right person
by the way we've also put together a
number of job listings along with links
to apply
you can find that on our website
8newsnow.com just click the job board
tab
christian